[Music]
down onto this KN and push closer down
on
try to stay up
don't as I
drop boom you can start feel where his
center of gravity is and come above it
okay make sure you're not pushing it
here come above wherever his you feel
his Center R the sound goes here
he's
heavy if your hand stays here then
you're not pushing push okay so as
you're dropping down this time going
that
way keep that leg
extended this
[Music]
the same thing boom up
here boom up all the way get get your
fist out okay and try to get his foot
above his hip at a
minimum here like this okay hold his
head pull it towards his knee and then
take him out this
way Smo boom pass boom
stay up with it movement boom
boom up grab his
head that's
it yes grab his
[Music]
head so same pull you feel the energy
you go with it
boom watch what I do I'm going to stack
him I push my
hips this way boom and you're down into
a
side push
forward aim for this hip don't aim for
side
control here aim for this hip and you'll
find side control at the
end shove your hips
forward slide down
[Music]
yes okay so when I when I push this
forward I'm
stacking you see it's so my weight's on
you okay and I'm not going to make this
go this way it's going to go that way
see how it turns you you see that all
right so you're here push forward this
stack slide down and I'm going to aim
for this shoulder that's the shoulder I
want okay and I want it right here on
that Kate and then I'll drive that
shoulder
in arm comes up out hips go forward boom
get that shoulder in place
boom Slide the pl return
so look my hips go forward the arm comes
out of the way and I'm on him here okay
once I get there you tell me what what
you what you feel
okay okay and what's going to
happen he's going to pass out okay so
he's going to know that so uh what do
you want to do what's your instinct to
not pass out what do you want to try to
do yes okay he's going to push with that
arm okay you got it so as as I do this
that's what I'm looking for when he
pushes with that
arm I'm here to get the reaction if if I
get it cool but most people will start
to push like that now I use my body to
get around that you see okay to get it
out and then take
it so he was
here you feel him push you'll feel that
okay when he does that I come to this
side like that and I start slipping it
out you have a couple options here you
can use this hand pass it over here
depends how good you get this part
that'll work too okay it's not a big
deal we try both but the main thing is
instigate the push feel the push take it
off
angle get
it here's
how we
land then you start to feel that see so
when you feel that what do you do that's
what you do all you see that and so
notice when I address the
arm you see that instantly MH notice
where my weight is where do you feel it
just on my chest it's on your chest it's
not way over here okay so we'll do it
again and
going is this enough that's what we want
to know do you understand it's enough
okay cuz you won't have any leverage try
to put your arm back you see cuz my my
body filled that space okay and then
it's easy py push don't let it
C so he's got his
frame if I put my
mass so that once I get it off
frame and it can't go back do do you see
that it's off frame now so now it's
easy it's only powerful here with the
elbows tight on his body okay so I'll
open everything up and you're going to
know that's where he's strong when he
starts to push you see come that that's
where I take the space now it's stay
there please now it's off right you see
that his elbows near his body that's all
I need so if I'm here look where his
shoulder is do you see won't let his
elbow go back and then tell me where you
feel the the heaviest
weight where you feel the heaviest
weight on my chest which chest uh left
or right my left chest my side do you
see so I go way over he pushes and I go
way over here then I'm we okay all I
need to do he pushes deframe him that's
it there's no leverage here there's no
leverage in that room
okay all right and then the more you do
that at the origin of his
push the smaller your movement is the
less energy it takes okay all right TR
so you you got it isolatable you come
around and he won't he you're like ah
not quite enough you could come here you
see you could come there but I can go
here and attack the elbow directly so I
don't try to go to the to the we Oni
classtic um I'm turning
this without letting that shoulder move
okay so if you pay attention this
shoulder wants to come up to take
rotation so come over
here and put weight on that shoulder you
tap when you don't like
it okay that's the technique so you're
here like this you're like I I don't
want to do that okay I'll go here and
I'll keep that shoulder
down without ever putting that hand down
okay El